welcome everyone to free code camp I
could lay on behalf of a dareka will
take this session on natural language
processing popularly known as NLP now
elder akka is a global elearning company
that provides all n training courses on
the latest trending technologies so
without any further delay let's have a
look at the agenda for this session so
I'll start off by explaining the
evolution of the human language then
we'll understand what is NLP and how it
came into the picture moving forward
we'll have a look at the various
application of NLP in the industry and
next we'll understand the different
components of NLP and the difficulties
faced while implementing those and
finally I'll finish off this video by
explaining you guys the various steps or
the paths involved in the natural
language processing
along with the demo for each one of
those steps so the success of human race
is because of our ability to communicate
that is information sharing using this
ability we have mashed ahead of other
animals and have become the most
sophisticated creatures and this is what
differentiates us among all the other
animals you begin to look for ways to
preserve our thoughts feelings messages
and other information we started with
oral communication like other animals
but because of its a formal nature we
began painting on walls and caves
who ever lived now there was a need to
standardize the drawing so that everyone
could understand and that's where the
concept of developing a language came in
how many such standards came up
resulting in many languages with each
language having its own basic sets of
alphabets combination of alphabets which
were known as words and the combination
of words which were arranged
meaningfully which became the sentence
now each language has a set of rules
based on words and are combined to form
these sentences now these set of rules
are nothing but what we call it as
grammar now I'm not gonna take any more
time explaining you guys about grammar
and all now coming to today's world
according to the industry estimates only
21 percent of the available data is
present in the structured form data has
been generated as we speak as we treat
as we send a message on whatsapp
Instagram
hi messaging and various other platforms
majority of this data exists in the
textual form which is highly
unstructured in nature now in order to
produce significant and actionable
insights from this text data it is
important to get acquainted with the
techniques and the principle of natural
language processing so let's understand
what exactly is NLP now natural language
processing that is NLP refers to the
artificial intelligence method
communicating with an intelligent system
using natural language now it is a part
of computer science and artificial
intelligence which deals with the human
language by utilizing NLP and components
one can organize the massive chunks of
text data perform numerous automated
tasks and solve a wide range of problems
such as automation summarization machine
translation named entity recognition
relationship extraction sentimental
analysis speech recognition and topic
segmentations now we'll learn about all
of these later in this video now the
goal here is to process all rather say
understand the natural language in order
to perform useful tasks some of these
stars includes making appointment buying
things spell checking generating
responses and social media monitoring
now if we look at the various
application of NLP in the industry
firstly we have the spell-checking
which is usually there in you can find
it mostly in words or the document
reader even online also you can do the
spell checking now next we have keyword
search and it is also a field where NLP
is heavily used
now extracting information from websites
or any particular document also requires
the knowledge of NLP now one of the
coolest application of NLP is the arrow
tease it matching which is basically a
recommendation of ads based on your
search what it does is analyzes the text
of the data which we are already using
or searched and match it with the text
data of the advertisement now sentiment
and analysis is also a very major part
of NLP
another application is the speaker
recognition now here we are also talking
about the voice assistants like the Siri
Google assistant the Cortana and we need
to thank Apple for creating the first
voice assistant that is Siri now next we
have the implementation of
BOTS now most of you guys might have
used the customer chat services provided
in various apps now most of these apps
use the chat bot which is it uses NLP to
process the data which we entered and
then it provides response based on an
input that is also an application of
natural language processing
now another application of NLP is the
machine translation now the most common
example of it is the Google Translate as
you know and now it uses NLP to
translate the data or I should all say
that text from one language to the other
and that too in real-time now NLP
consists of two components which is the
natural language understanding referred
to as NLU and the natural language
generation which is referred to as nlg
now understanding the natural language
involves mapping the giving an input in
natural language into useful
representation and analyzing different
aspects of the language now natural
language generation is the process of
producing meaningful phrases and
sentences in the form of ratcher
language from some internal
representation now it involves text
planning which includes retrieving the
relevant contents from the knowledgebase
it involves sentence planning which
includes choosing require words from
meaningful phrases setting tone of the
sentences and finally we have text
realization it is mapping sentence plan
into the sentence structure now we'll
learn about this later in this video
and usually natural language
understanding which is NLU is much much
harder than energy now you might be
thinking that even a small child can
understand a language so how come it is
so easy for human beings are so
difficult for the computer to process it
so let's understand what are the
difficulties a machine faces while
understanding a language so in natural
language understanding there are certain
ambiguities which are the lexical
ambiguity syntactical ambiguity and the
referential ambiguity now understanding
a new language is very hard taking our
english into consideration there are a
lot of ambiguity and that too in
different levels now starting with
lexical ambiguity lexical ambiguity is
the presence of two or more possible
meanings
single wood it is also called semantic
ambiguity for example let's consider the
following sentences and let's focus on
the italicized wood now she is looking
for a match now what do we infer here
from the match world is she looking for
a match that is head-to-head match what
is she looking for a match as in a
partner the fisherman went to a bank is
it the bank where we withdraw our money
or is it the bank
mary-rose his boat or he cashes the
fishes now syntactical ambiguity in
English grammar this ambiguity is the
presence of two or more possible
meanings within a single sentence or a
sequence of words it is also called
structural ambiguity or grammatical
ambiguity now let's have a look at these
sentences the chicken is ready to eat
so is the chicken ready to eat something
or is the chicken ready for us to eat so
this is a kind of syntactical ambiguity
which is often very hard to info for a
new person or as I say a computer
because it means the meaning of the
sentence is different for the different
tones or in different aspects so for
example if I look at the last statement
I saw the man with the binoculars so do
I have a binocular or the man has a
binocular it might be possible that you
might be thinking that oh I saw the man
with binoculars means that I have the
binoculars but somewhere some people
might think that the guy which I am
seeing has the binoculars rather than me
so that is syntactically ambiguity now
coming to the third ambiguity which is
the referential ambiguity now this
ambiguity arises when we refer to
something using pronouns now the boy
told his father the theft he was very
upset now when we talk about he was very
upset if you focus on the italicized
word he does this mean that the boy was
upset or the thief was upset or the
father was upset nobody knows this is
referential ambiguity now
back to NLP for using NLP on to a system
or doing any natural language processing
we need to install the NL ticket library
that is the natural language toolkit so
NL DK is a leading platform for building
Python programs to work with human
language data it provides easy-to-use
interfaces to 50 corpora and lexical
resources such as wordnet along with the
suit of text processing libraries for
classification tokenization stemming
tagging and much more now let me show
you how you can download an l TK now in
order to download analytic it just go to
your Python shell and just type in the
word n LT K dot download using the
parentheses and then you will get this
type of a window pop-up which is the NL
ticket downloader you just need to
select all option and click on the
download button and it will download all
the corpora and the text it has all the
packages it has into one single place
and you can choose the directory where
you want to install it it's better if
you download it in your Python directory
only it will be easier for you to access
all the files and all the text which it
has to offer now when we process text
there are a few terminologies which we
need to understand so the first
terminology here we are talking about is
tokenization so it is a process of
breaking up strings into tokens which in
turn are small structures or units that
can be used for tokenization now it
involves three steps breaking a complex
sentence into words understanding the
importance of each of the words with
respect to the sentence and produce a
structural description on an input
sentence so if we take the sentence
today we will understand tokenization so
as you can see we have five tokens the
first one today we will understand
tokenization so all of these words in
computer terms are known as tokens and
this is what is referred to as
tokenization so let me show you guys how
you can implement tokenization using the
analytical library
so here I'm using Jupiter notebook you
are free to use any sort of ID also my
personal preference is Jupiter notebook
so first of all let's import the OS the
NL DK library which we have download and
the NL ticket corpus now let's have a
look at the corpora which is being
provided by the NL TK that is the whole
data so as you can see we have so many
files and all of these files have
different functionalities some have
textual data some have different
functions associated with it we have
stopped was as you can see here your
state union names we had Twitter sample
data we have different kind of data and
different kind of functions here so
let's take the brown into consideration
as you can see we have brown and brown
zip so first of all we need to do is
import the brown and then let's have a
look at the words which I present in the
brown you can see we have the fruit on
contrary gradually said and it's going
on and on now let's have a look at the
different Gutenberg feeds so as you can
see under Gutenberg file we have Austin
M our text we have the Bible text we
have the plate poems the Carol Alice
text you have the H worth parents taught
takes the Shakespeare's we have we have
this Shakespeare we have the Whitman
Leaves so analytical is a very big
directory and a very big library to
download you might need a couple of
minutes to download this library so
let's take the Shakespeare Hamlet dot
txt and if you look at the words which
are inside this Hamlet file we see it
starts with the tragedy of Hamlet pie
and it goes on and on so if we have a
look at the first 500 words of this
textual paragraph or what will the text
well file so I'm using here for word in
Hamlet and I'm using the colon and 500
that is the endpoint so as you can see
it starts as the tragedy of Hamlet by
William Shakespeare 1599 act as Primus
scone a primer and it goes on and on so
for natural language processing you can
use either of the text which is provided
here for understanding or you can create
your own words
so for example here I have defined a
paragraph based on artificial
intelligence okay so it goes on like
according to the father of artificial
intelligence John McCarthy it is the
science of engineering and so on and on
so let us first define this string okay
yeah now why I am taking a string is
because it is easy to show you guys how
to work on a string so if we do the type
AI you can see it is STR which is string
now under n LT K we have the NL ticket
dot tokenize and we are going to import
the word tokenized
right as a function will understand how
it works now we will run the word
underscore tokenized function over the
paragraph and assign it a name let's
assign it as a i underscore tokens so
now if we'll have a look at the and the
score tokens you can see it has divided
the whole AI paragraph which we gave
into tokens so as you can see it has
taken a comma also into consideration
the - also and it goes on and on now
let's have a look at the number of
tokens where we have here so for that we
are going to use the length function so
as you can see we have 273 tokens now
from n l TK we have a probability
function which is the frequency distinct
so I'll show you what it does so far a
word in EA and escort tokens F test and
we are going to convert it to lowercase
so as to avoid the probability of
considering a word with uppercase and
lowercase as different and then we are
going to assign it a number this is
basically a word count program and this
is being implemented using the frequency
distinct function which is already
present in the analytical library so
let's see what's the output of this one
so as you can see it comma has appeared
30 times
full-stop has appeared nine times
question mark 1 and so on and on like
you see intelligence has appeared 6 time
intelligent 6 time intelligently has
appeared one time now suppose if you
want to know the frequency of any
particular word here so for that we are
going to use the function f test that is
the distinct frequency so we are going
to use that function over the particular
word so for example let's say I want to
know the freak
Quincy of artificial so as you can see
it is three times and if we check it in
the database you can see it is
artificial it is given as three now if
you want to have an look at the number
of distinct words here all we need to do
is pass on the f-test function to the
length function so you can see it's 1:21
so earlier we had 273 tokens and now
from that we have 121 distinct tokens
now suppose if we were to select the top
10 tokens with the highest frequency for
that I am assigning a new F this
underscore top 10 and I am using the
most underscore common function here and
passing 10 that is the number of items I
want so let's see the output so as you
can see as I mentioned earlier comma
appears 30 times that is the highest
frequency of any world and is appears
five times so these are the top ten
words which are the most reoccurring
quotes in the given paragraph or the
given sentence
now let's use the plant client tokenizer
over the same string to tokenize a
paragraph with respect to a blank string
so as you can see we are importing the
blank line and the score tokenize
earlier what we did was import the word
underscore tokenize and now we are using
the blank line under course croak nice
and again we are passing the same AI
paragraph which i gave earlier and then
we are checking the length of the a a
and the scope plank so as you can see it
provides us the output 9 now what it
tells us is the number of paragraphs
which are separated by a new line in our
given document so suppose you want to
have a look at the first paragraph or
supposedly the second paragraph
why don't you do is pass on the number
and it will give you the whole paragraph
as you want which is separated by a new
line of course now coming back to our
tokenization part we have diagrams
trigrams and engrams now diagrams are
tokus of two consecutive written words
similarly diagrams are refer to tokus of
three consecutive written words and
usually engrams is referred to as tokens
of any number of consecutive written
words for n numbers so let us see how we
can implement the same using analytical
libraries for by Graham's diagrams and
the N Crump's so first what we need to
do is import backgrounds trigrams and
engrams from NLT k dot util so let's
take a string the best and the most
visual thing in the world cannot be seen
or even test they must be filled with
the heart
what a beautiful code so let us now
first create the tokens of the whole
string using the word underscore
tokenized as I did earlier now to create
a diagram what we need to do is use the
list function and inside that we are
going to use the NL ticket or diagrams
and pass on the tokens
so as you can see it has created a
bigram of the given document similarly
if we create the trigrams at the end
grounds so all you need to do is change
the backgrounds to trigrams it will give
you the trigram list now let us now
create an Engram list okay so guys as
you can see here we are using the same
portion and I'll take a dot engrams
and inside that we are passing the
quotes and the course token and here in
place of n we are going to give our
number so let's say suppose I provide
five here so as you can see it has given
us an Engram of length five now once we
have got all the words or as I'll say
the tokens we need to make some changes
to the tokens and for that we have
stemming now what stemming does is
normalized the words into its base root
form so if you have a look at the world
severe effect ation effects affections
affected affection and affecting now all
of these words originate from a single
root world that is the effect now
stemming algorithms works by cutting off
the end or the beginning of the word
taking into account a list of common
prefixes and suffixes that can be found
in an infected port now this in
discriminated cutting can be successful
in some occasions but not always and
that is why we affirm that this approach
presents some limitations now let's see
how we can implement stemming and we'll
see what are the limitations of stemming
and how we can overcome them now there
are quite a few different types of stem
so let's start with the porter stemmer
so for that we are going to use from NLT
cured stem import Porter simmer and
let's see what does this give us the
output of stemming the word having so
you can see it has given us the root
word have
so similarly if we provide a list of
words such as you give giving given and
gave and I have given this name of words
to stem so four words in verse system
French words and we are using the porter
stemmer which is the PST dot stem method
so as you can see it has given us the
output give give given and gave so you
can see the stem Oh remove the only ing
and replace it with E
now there is another stammer which is
known as the Lancaster stammer so let's
try to stem the same thing using the
Lancaster stem and see what is the
difference so let's stem the same thing
using the Lancaster stem and see what
are the differences we have so first of
all we are going to import the land cast
system and we are going to provide LST
which is the length care system of
function and in the similar manner that
we did for the porter stemmer let us
execute the line cast system also so as
you can see here this demo has stemmed
all the words as a result of it you can
conclude that the Lancaster steamer is
more aggressive than the porter stemmer
now the use of each of the stem owns
depend on the type of the tasks you want
to perform now we have another steamer
which is known as the snowball steamer
now for snowball steamer we have to
provide the language which we are using
so similarly if we use the snowball
steamer on the given words as you can
see it has given us a different output
from the previous Lancaster steamer so
as you can see the output is the same as
that of the porter stemmer here but it
differs in different terms now the use
of each of this steamer depends on the
time of the task you want to perform for
example if you want to check how many
times the word G IV is used above you
can use the lancaster steamer and for
other purposes you have the snowballs
number and the porter stemmer as well so
what happens is that sometimes stemming
does not work properly it does not
always result to give us the root word
so for example if we take the word fish
and fishes and fishing all of that stems
into fish so limitation is an another
concept so on one hand we're stemming
usually works by cutting off the end and
the beginning of the word limit ization
takes into consideration the
morphological analysis of the world so
to do so it is necessary to have a
detailed dictionary which the algorithm
can look into to link the form back to
its lemma
now what Limited Edition does is groups
together different infected forms of the
word called lemma it is somehow similar
to stemming as it map several words into
one common root now one thing to keep in
consideration here is the output of
limit ization is a proper word so for
example if we look back to our output
given by the lancaster's demo you can
see it has given us the output giv which
is not a word so the output of limit
ization is a proper word and for example
if you take a limit ization of
gone going it all goes into the word go
now again we can see how it works with
the same an example of words let's try
and limit ization using the NLT key
library so first of all we are going to
import the word net as mentioned earlier
it requires additionally which the
algorithm can look into to link back the
form into its conditional lemma and
since the output is a perfect world so
it needs to have addition so for here we
are going to import the word meditation
Airy and we are going to import the word
net lemma tiser so let us first take the
word corpora and see what its lemma is
so what do you think guys what will be
the output as you can see it has given
the right output which is the corpus so
let's use limit ization on the given
words so as you can see here the limit
Iser has kept the words as it is this is
because we haven't assigned any POS tags
and hence it has assumed all the words
as none now we'll learn about POS later
in this video but just to give you a
hint of what viewers is POS is basically
paths of speech
so as certifying which word is a noun
which is a pronoun and which is a
subject and much more
now do you know there are several words
in the English language such as I at 4
begin gone no where is
thought of as useful in the formation of
sentence and without it the sentences
won't even make sense but these do not
provide any help in NLP so these lists
of words are known as stop words so you
might be confused as if are they helpful
or not it is helpful in the English
language but it is not helpful in the
language processing so NL TK has its own
list of stop words you can use the same
by importing it from NLT corpus so once
we import the stop words we can just
have a look at the different stompers
which is provided by an LC here so we
need to mention which language we are
using so let's have a look at the number
of stop words we have an English format
so just 1/7 is 9 so remember guys when
we use the F dist underscore top 10 to
check the top 10 tokens which have the
highest number of frequency so let us
take that again
so as you can see here apart from the
world intelligence and intelligent all
of the words are usually stop words so
basically I should say that they do not
match any particular word they're like
special digits and characters which do
not add any value to the language
processing and hence it can be removed
so first of all we will use the compiled
from the re module to create a string
that matches any digit or the special
character now we will create an empty
list and append the words without any
punctuation into the list so I'm naming
this as post punctuation and if you have
a look at the output of the post
punctuation so as you can see it has
removed all the various numbers and
digits and the comma and the different
elements now when I was talking about
POS which is parts of speech now
generally speaking the grammatical type
of the word the verb the noun adjective
add row' an article now it indicates how
a word functions in meaning as well as
grammatically within the sentence a word
can have more than one parts of speech
based on the context in which it is used
for example if we take the sentence GU
or something on the internet now here
quill is used as a verb although it is a
proper noun so these are some sort of
ambiguities and the difficulties which
makes the natural language understanding
even much more harder as compared to
natural language generation because once
you understand the language generation
is pretty easy so POS stacks are usually
used to describe whether the word is a
noun and adjective or pronoun a proper
noun singular Prowler whoa is it a
symbol is it an adverb so you can see
here we have so many tags and
descriptions for the different kinds of
words all the way ranging from
coordinating conjunction to what work
WRP now let's take an example of these
two sentences so the first sentence is
the waiter clears the plates from the
table so as you can see from the
starting if we use the world take into
consideration the it is a determiner
now waiter is a noun cleared is a verb
though is again Data Miner the plates
are noun from it's not defined here
there is again the determiner and the
table is again a noun
now again if we take into consideration
the sentence the dog ate the cat
similarly those the determiner dog noun
8 is the verb and again it's the same
determiner and the note so let's see how
we can implement POS tags and do the
tagging using the analytical library so
let us take a sentence Timothy is a
natural minute comes to drawing first of
all will tokenize it using the word
unscored tokenize and then we are going
to use the POS underscore tag on all of
these tokens so as if you see it has
defined Timothy as a noun is as a work
as a determiner natural as an adjective
when as a WRP projective and it has a
preposition it comes as a verb too and
drawing as a verb as well now let us
take another example that John is eating
a delicious cake so as you can see here
the tagger has tagged both the is and
eating as work because it has consider
is eating as a single term now this is
one of the small shortcomings of the POS
taggers when it comes to tying the words
now another concept in natural language
processing is NER which is known as
named entity recognition so the process
of detecting the named entities such as
a movie a monetary value will be it an
organization location quantities and a
person from a text is known as named
entity recognition now there are three
phases of any of which is first is a
noun phrase identification now this step
deals with extracting all the noun
phrases from a text using dependency
passing and parts of speech tagging
which is the POS tag now secondly we
have the phrase classification now this
is the classification step in which all
the extractor nouns and phrase are
classified into respective categories
such as location names and much more now
apart from this one can cure
the look-up tables and dish Nerys by
combining information from the different
sources and finally we have the entity
disambiguation now sometimes it is
possible that the entities are
misclassified hence creating a
validation layer hunter how the result
is very useful the use of knowledge
graphs can be exploited for this purpose
now the popular knowledge graphs are the
Google knowledge graph the IBM Watson
and also Wikipedia so if we have a look
at a certain example suppose this is the
sentence the Google's CEO sundar Pichai
introduced a new pixel add Minnesota ROI
Center event so as you can see Google is
an organization sundar Pichai is a
person Minnesota is a location and ROI
Center event is also an organization
this is an additional layer on top of
the POS tagging so as to clarify and
give us more depth into what the
sentence is about and what the sentence
is conveying us so for using any R in
Python you need to import the any
underscore chunk from the NLT here
module in Python so once we have
imported any underscore chunk now let us
take this sentence into consideration
which is the US president stays in the
White House now again what we need to do
is tokenize the sentence and after
tokenizing what we need to do is add the
viewers tags so that it will be easier
for us to conclude the ners so we are
passing the any underscore tags into any
underscore chunks function and let's see
what's the output so as you can see it
has given T as a determiner it has given
us as an organization and White House is
clubbed together as a single entity I'll
just consider it as a facility so as you
can see adding a layer of dictionary and
then adding the tags and then creating
the named entity recognition makes the
understanding of language so much more
easier
now as you can see in the nei entity
list we have geo social political group
in geopolitical entity we have facility
location organization and person says
it's all just from the previous example
as you can see if he has given
organization we have facility now an
important thing to consider in NLP is
also the syntax now in in linguistics
syntax is the set of rules principles
and the processes that govern the
structure of a sentence in a given
language the terms syntax is also used
to refer to the study of such principles
and processes so we have a certain rules
as to what part of sentence should come
up at what position now with these rules
we create a syntax tree whenever there
is a sentence as an input so syntax tree
in laymen terms is basically a tree
representation of the syntactic
structure of sentences or strengths now
it is a way of representing the syntax
of a programming language as a
hierarchical tree like structure and
this structure is used for generating
symbol tables for compilers and later
code generation the tree represents all
the constructs in the language and their
subsequent rules now consider the
statement the cat sat on a mat so as you
can see this is how a syntax tree looks
like we have a sentence we have the noun
phrase the preposition phrase and again
the noun phrase is divided into article
and noun then we have the verb which is
sat again we have the preposition which
is on and again finally we have the noun
phrase which consists of article and the
norm now in order to render syntax trees
in your notebook you need to install go
strips which is a rendering engine
so you can download go straight from
this downloads page I'll not go much
into the details of that now let us
discuss an important concept with
respect to analyzing the sentence
structure which is chunking now chunking
basically means picking up individual
pieces of information and grouping them
into bigger pieces so as we saw earlier
that we have a sentence and we divided
it in two different tokens that was
tokenization and this is sort of like
the opposite part or we should say the
opposite of what we were known as
tokenization a little bit of changes to
that localization part we'll see what
are the different changes now the bigger
pieces are usually known as chunks here
now in the context of NLP chunking means
grouping of words or the tokens into
chunks now let's have a look at the
example of chunking here so let's
consider the statement we caught the
Pink Panther so as you can see here the
pink which is an adjective Panther which
is a noun and third which is the
determiner are charged together into a
noun phrase now this also helps in
determining and the processing of the
language so suppose if someone is asking
whom did we caught this morning so the
regular response to this question would
be we caught the Pink Panther now the
question is asking who so the Pink
Panther becomes a noun phrase basically
so this is something what the chunking
does is that it understands the language
and once it has understood what it does
is basically picks up the individual
pieces of information and groups them
into chunks so that it will be easier
for us to process that data so let's
take a new sentence the big cat ate
little mouse who was after the fresh
cheese so let's tokenize it and add the
purist tags also so as you can see just
another one line or I should say in one
command I have tokenized it and I've
added the POS tags also so let's define
the parameter
so next what we are going to do is
create a regular expression parser for
the grammar NP which is the grammar
which we have provided and then we'll
create the chunk underscore result and
we'll pass this whole sentence or I
should say the tokens into the chunks
there was a slider as NLT he was unable
to file the Jia's file but as you can
see here we have a tree in which the NP
is the big cat the big cat is a noun
phrase it is a verb tree then again we
have the non phrase which is the little
mouse who is a word phrase Wars is a
verb after is in and again we have the
noun phrase the fresh cheese so you can
see here although we do not have a
particular tree like structure we can
see that from the outer we can see we
have a tree starting from the start is
here and the end is here I can see it
starts with the noun phrase the big cat
now the big cat
as I mentioned earlier in our previous
example similarly to the beeping Panther
it is being taken into consideration as
a noun phrase which is basically a chant
it has created different chunks in the
given sentence I should say so this is
it guys I hope you got an idea of what
the different parts of NLP is what is
NLP how it is used the different
elements of NLP such as starting from
tokenization stop words stemming limit
ization again we have the stop words
part of speech
POS tags NER named entity recognition
and after NER we had the syntax we
created a syntax tree to know how
exactly the sentence is arranged and how
it uses it additionally the purest tax
and the tokenization to create a
particular tree so as to form a meaning
out of the sentence and finally we are
using chunking as to chunk together the
small tokens into meaningful words so
guys I hope you liked this session and
I'm sure you guys will start
implementing these procedures on the
given text using the analytical error
and let me tell you one thing guys the
analytical area is filled with lots and
lots of text
data and lots and lots of example this
is just the beginning of it and you can
dig deeper into an L piece and go into
topics like context-free grammar and
much more which is already there in the
analytical package and is very useful
when it comes to natural language
processing thank you